from this balcony in the sunshine of the
Vatican Pope Francis used his Easter
message to warn about Darkness
he called for an end to the gloom and
conflicts that envelope the world help
for the ukrainians more help for
turkey's earthquake victims and that's
all too familiar prayer for peace in the
Middle East
I expressed deep concern about the
recent attacks which threatened the
desired climate of trust and reciprocal
respect necessary to resume dialogue
between Israelis and Palestinians so
that peace May reign in the holy city
and the entire region
more than 40
000 follow
tent perhaps at seeing him in person
after poor health had threatened the
Pope's Easter engagements
a thousand miles away in Canterbury the
same message
light over Darkness life over death and
a warning that there will be divine
Justice
we do not lose heart but we pray and we
work for Ukraine and Russia for Israel
and Palestine with the recent tragedies
especially and for the others so often
forgotten struggles of our world as we
are surrounded by fears even by evil
we know that those who oppress and
subjugate others will face Divine
Justice
on a day that marks New Beginnings a new
king led his family to Easter Mass his
first since his mother's death and on
the second anniversary of his father's
a once outspoken Prince stuck to Royal
tradition for a quiet and private Easter
on the Windsor estate Saudia Chaudhary
Sky News